cyber criminals are becoming
increasingly aggressive and they're
counting on your organization to have a
fractured response to their bad behavior
but you can take back the upper hand by
developing a new unified risk operations
center strategy
this strategy uses machine learning and
open platforms to enable you to detect
attacks that previously would have gone
unnoticed
so the problem with what we're doing
today is risk management is really being
built in silos we have a department for
anti-fraud we'll have a different
department for anti-money laundering
we've got the security operations center
corporate security insider threat and
the the issue is that all of these
different groups are duplicating their
effort they have duplicate data tools
and tactics and duplicate processes
and ultimately this results in gaps and
inconsistencies that cyber criminals
really love to exploit
so let's take a little look at an
example scenario today we're going to
have our attacker who's going after our
unsuspecting victim jim
so our attacker is going to send jim an
email a phishing email which contains
malware
so jim's a nice guy he's not expecting
to be phished today he opens that email
which results in his banking credentials
being sent to our attacker
our attacker then uses these credentials
to log into jim's bank account but jim
was smart jim set up second factor
authentication
unfortunately our attacker is pretty
crafty and steals jim's mobile number by
performing an illegitimate sim swap
so now he's able to approve the second
factor authentication challenge which
gives him full access to jim's bank
account
with this access he then buys 500 000
worth of cryptocurrency which he then
transfers to different mule accounts
uses a crypto laundering service to make
this unable to be traced back to him
so we can have a think about how our
different departments might detect and
respond to this today
our security operations center might say
that this is actually just legitimate
behavior there's nothing suspicious
here our anti-fraud department might say
that this looks like a case of
compromised credentials
and our anti-money laundering department
might actually say that jim was the one
who was laundering money
so the point is all these different
departments don't have full visibility
into what took place which means that
none of them can respond accurately and
timely to the incident
so how are we going to bring power back
to the organization
well we can bridge the gap by building a
unified risk operation center strategy
so this strategy uses uh makes use of a
couple of core principles so one being
using data wherever it lives in whatever
format from across the organization
consolidating that data to make it
accessible
we also use machine learning and risk
profiling at the core
and we build consistent workflows on top
of this data and the machine learning
insights that we get so that everything
is handled consistently across the
organization
and finally this is a consumable service
so that other parts of the business
other applications and services are able
to use the insights that we're getting
out of our risk analytics
okay so how do we get there this is an
iterative journey it doesn't happen
overnight what we do is we pick some use
cases and we build on them each time
proving value to the organization of
doing so
so to start with here we're going to
start by integrating our anti-fraud and
our anti-money laundering departments
so at this point we've got a small swarm
team which has got a couple of people
from the different groups
we're starting to do joint strategy and
operations planning between these groups
and we're also rationalizing the tools
and controls between them
so what can we detect now well our
anti-money laundering department might
have noticed that this money went to a
crypto laundering service
and our anti-fraud department might have
noticed that you know this transaction
took place at an unusual time of day
so from here we can start to remediate
we can start to take action on these
insights so we could automatically block
future access to this account
and we can automatically notify the
authorities so that we're preventing
future losses to the business
okay so our next step is then to scale
up so now we're going to pull in
information from our security operations
center and our corporate security groups
so now our swarm team is getting bigger
we're including people from these new
departments we're also further
rationalizing the tools and controls so
we're reducing that duplicate
set of tools in the organization
and at this phase of maturity you're
really starting to make these insights
consumable so other parts of the
business can use the the rich insights
that we're building here
okay so what are we going to be able to
detect now well the sock might be able
to tell us that our organization is
being targeted at the moment by a
phishing campaign
we might also know that jim had malware
on his device at the time of compromise
and we can start to pull in information
from other third parties so the telco
might be able to tell us that you know
the sim swap that took place was
actually illegitimate or in fact we
could look up information about recent
activity on jim's account
so now what can we do with this
information well we can see how the
attacker got access in the first place
which means we can start to remediate
and ensure that this type of attack
doesn't take place again in the future
okay so now we want to do our final
iteration we want our fully fledged
unified risk operations center
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to make sure that all of the
departments in our organization are
integrated into this platform so we're
pulling data from wherever it lives in
the organization
and what if whatever format it lives in
we are able to do to consolidate this
data so that we can do machine learning
on top of it and we're getting those
risk insights associated with all
different types of entities throughout
the environment we also have
well-defined workflows so we can
automatically deal with known threats
and we have a really well-structured way
for dealing with unknown threats
and of course as i mentioned before this
is all consumable so other parts of the
business can use this information
okay so now what can we detect at this
final phase well all the pieces of the
puzzle are starting to come together we
might be able to see things like this
device that was used to authenticate
the attacker was actually a new device
which in itself isn't an indicator of
fraud but it does increase the
suspiciousness of this particular
incident
we can also correlate this with other
information from consortium data for
example and we could say okay well we've
actually seen this device be used for
fraud in the past
we can do machine learning on different
parts of our environment so we could do
machine learning on jim's usual
transaction so the transaction value and
the transaction type which would flag
this particular transaction as an
anomaly
and ultimately what we're doing is we're
pulling all these little pieces of risk
information together to be able to
inform real-time decisions so in this
case we can prevent this transaction
from ever actually having taken place
anyway
okay so we know that our existing
mechanisms of building risk management
around specific silos isn't sustainable
we need to bring together the data the
tools and the people in order to be able
to effectively manage risk
consider your risk management
modernization journey and have a think
about how unified risk operation center
strategy could help you manage risk now
and into the future
thank you if you like this video and
want to see more like it please like and
subscribe
if you have questions please drop them
in the comments below